through just one t-shirt he literally
hijacked the entire Fashion Week that's
true which has never happened before
[Music]
in recent news bar Kwan is a huge Limp
Bizkit fan I've been learning about bart
today I have to say I've been learning a
lot about bart today but less important
Kanye West faces backlash for wearing a
shirt with white lives matter slogan hey
great
hey
yes your [ __ ] response let's go
you guys are back on top
all right so before we get into any of
the details clean what do you think
um
well
where should I start
I don't I don't like Kanye West so I I
don't follow anything that he does what
don't you like about him I thought
you're gonna say
the best news I've heard all day we're
back baby business is booming White
lives matter push it to the Limit who
said recession
so Connie sure could have said anything
you wouldn't have agreed
um no I just don't I don't follow the
news with him so what if you said save
the White Rhino
is that [ __ ] up it feels kind of
[ __ ] up now doesn't it save the White
Rhino I think you should at least put it
rhinos matter would have been a good
shirt that would have been a great shirt
to be honest that would have been a
gangsters dude they are in real trouble
what's a rhino dude
no no no white white red I've been
learning so much about bart today I know
it's short for rhinoceros
is it slain for something Bart what does
the Rhino what sound does the Rhino make
this make no sound okay nice if you had
to guess
well I wanted to make him feel insecure
sounds dude it worked dude Connie's an
expert at like getting people riled up
though man he's a [ __ ] expert Connie
is good at trolling for sure oh he's a
genius at it I'll I will always say
Kanye is a genius at that whether I like
it or yeah whether or not yeah you know
I always feel like it's a bigger play
you can't deny when I hear Kanye news
I'm always like he's up to something so
for context at uh the Paris fashion week
uh his show on Monday Kanye AKA wore a
shirt with the phrase White lives matter
on the back alongside him was
conservative commentator Candace Owens
who wore the same shirt in white let me
just go and send a photo your way
a little bit of context or should I say
Kanye text by the way this is probably
the weirdest part of this one for me
personally she's a married woman and I
believe they're holding hands there yeah
I don't like that I don't like that one
bit wow I think Candace Owens is going
to make a video talking about how she
[ __ ] up she should make it I think she
should but I think they're standing in
solidarity it has Candace Owens ever
made a [ __ ] up video no she shits on
everybody though don't you yeah
what do you think a strategy is behind
this attention attention for album
well let me let me at least add one
anecdote before people make assumptions
that are completely like off The Rocker
because I got my own hypothesis one
important thing is that they also had to
make a very public statement that black
lives matter was a scam
wow I think it's important and then now
what do you guys think with the
intentions of rock are we talking about
the real estate [ __ ]
no no because no black lives matter got
busted like spending [ __ ] tons of money
on oh I I think organization okay I
think yeah the whole organization so
that was playing a part of the entire
concept of what the scan was whether it
be the money or whatever but quote
unquote everyone knows that black lives
matter was a scam now it's over you're
welcome damn that's their statement
that's why that was on his Twitter
account I believe and then it's it's
been recently deleted for whatever
reasons but that's his State a lot of
things that he posts gets deleted right
after so when I saw this this was my
like
my analysis from my own small
perspective
uh I think for for black people they're
like what the [ __ ] like you're literally
destroying what we're trying to do which
is BLM black lives matter regardless if
it's the organization that is Shady or
just the sentiment of like yeah cops
stop [ __ ] harassing our neighborhoods
and other people right so I understand
that
but that's like regular people like us
when we see things like we we get pissed
or we have a certain emotion towards
things because we're very uh what is it
called like less calculated if you will
Kanye is like so many like step like you
got people play Streetball then you got
like amateur then you got Semi-Pro then
you got Pro then you got LeBron James
and you got like the best of the best I
think Kanye is operating on a level that
maybe a lot of people aren't able to
think about so even from my like naive
and and like small perspective looking
at the whole context of everything he
just went to war with Adidas right
trying to get all his own [ __ ] back at
the same time we've even heard from uh
like Bobby where he was like I probably
would never work with him because he's
too [ __ ] crazy he's just like a
really hard Beast to tame but if he
works with any brand he will literally
have you explode it so at the same time
this guy is also beefing with all of the
luxury brand owners like LV what I think
he called out a guy named something
Arnold like he runs the LV and Mage
whatever company
so I think in his own personal way of
Waging War because he did just tweet
that I think maybe last week like it's
going to be war and I don't know who's
addressing that to
through just one t-shirt he literally
hijacked the entire Fashion Week that's
true which has never happened before
like that whole like you literally saw
what Gigi Hadid or whatever yeah yeah
with a spray-on pink that was like whoa
that's the most craziest [ __ ] we've ever
seen for five seconds because literally
it's like you you have the most amazing
like almost like
louvrey piece gets slapped the [ __ ] out
and this guy have like a Gildan long
shirt and he just [ __ ] screen prints
one color by Gildan [ __ ] t-shirt and
I think that's him going like to you to
Louis Vuitton [ __ ] on everybody
I know [ __ ] um Fashion Week type
people [ __ ] you I will cause more [ __ ]
than you guys so that's that's how I'm
pursuing you guys wouldn't you do that
if you could if you had the resources
and the platform I don't even think I'm
smart enough to play
possibly most of us even if you were
that uh let's just uh for the lack of a
better turn let's say there was
smartness let's say there was Brilliance
to that I think that most regular human
beings will still have a filter we'll
still have a moment where you're like
that's maybe not a good idea to go that
far because it's so it's so um again to
I don't know try to transcend my own
mentality and go to this like upper
echelon like you said like not being
able to comprehend the type of Genius
that somebody like that would do it's
like
let me hypothesize in a weird way what
if he was like oh [ __ ] all this theme
about like you know uh racism and
Justice and systemic racism and black
people in general
it's all gone nobody's talking about
anymore how do we bring it back let's
make it controversial let me be a martyr
to the system let me be let me be
somebody who brings the conversation
back even if I'm not looked at as the
hero of it but just the fact that the
conversations happen like an anti-hero
exactly the anti-hero
in a way it almost feels like that and I
only say that because I believe it was a
a Marbury right uh his uh modern Arbury
yeah it was his mom who had recently put
out a statement about how she was like
also kind of like you know uh not
satisfied not happy about the way that
Kanye was going about this because it
was very contradictory to his actions of
him silently donating to Ahmad arbory's
uh like funeral
you know what I'm saying so you're kind
of like wait a minute this guy like on
the back end quietly is willing to like
help and be a part of that movement and
support the family like a very direct
without any heroic like I need like put
I need to put I don't need Paparazzi I
don't need to like shiny I'll just do it
yeah but then on the front end where it
doesn't seem like it makes sense it's
overly radical it's like let me
publicize the fact that I'm doing
something that's gonna stir up
conversation controversy maybe a
byproduct of the action but conversation
a guaranteed byproduct of it right I
mean what's the worst that could happen
to Kanye West
like people are gonna try to cancel him
they've been trying to do that for a
long time for everything no matter what
no matter what so at this point it's not
like he's really taking a risk no was it
Kanye during Hurricane Katrina that was
like George Bush did not care about
black people oh yeah on the TV on TV and
then Chris Tucker's like oh
it was Mike Myers yeah they cut to Chris
Tucker afterwards and he's like uh
so he's [ __ ] used to this game plan
he likes the heat yeah he's so good at
it and what he did to Taylor Swift yeah
everyone remembers that dude this is
this is his [ __ ] field man he's an
expert at this [ __ ] yeah he he's playing
he's he's playing another level and it's
like I clearly don't know what the [ __ ]
he's doing anyway we'll only see what
happens yeah because then to see the
needle that he's trying to push around I
think are in like [ __ ] uh like the
nine to ten digit realm you know what I
mean like he's like that's where he's
moving the needle so like if you have
your angel and devil on your shoulder
they're like but what about the people
who I think for him he's like I don't
give a [ __ ] about what [ __ ] Joe Blow
thinks yeah I'm moving things in the
[ __ ] building a multi-billion
direction I don't even think any of that
matters statistically how the average
person thinks of what he's doing doesn't
[ __ ] change it he's not even thinking
that that's not even in his strategy
plan dude every news Outlet is talking
about this like everybody is I mean
that's very hard to do the top news
outlets us CNN
everybody's just agreeing with each
other [ __ ] you guys this is just wrong
we should just say it's wrong okay
so that that's what I just said
that's what's wrong with uh White lives
matter huh
so you're on the record saying that you
think what Kanye did is wrong I think it
was pretty clear
so how much are you pledging to wlm
I didn't say that I said it was wrong
didn't I so if somebody gave you a fresh
little Kanye shirt which is worth a lot
of money wait wait I said it was wrong I
know but you're the one wearing the
Kanye shirt I'm the one wearing the
owner Kirkland not Kanye and it says
white lives matter shirt and it's a
brand it's brand spanking you it's Kanye
West and he gave it to you would you
wear it at home
wait why would I wear it you'd be the
one wearing a piece of shoes
I was the one saying group think is
wrong why are you guys being all group
thinky let's be more like me and be
counter the group thinky and let's do
the other thing
[Laughter]
there's a diddy interview that was going
around
um and then he was like man him and
Kanye are buddies you know so he was
like man why you got to do that man why
you got to do that he goes I was gonna
drop this shirt that says Kanye or
nothing because I think he wants to like
he just thinks he's like a brilliant
mind so he wants to support him he goes
no I can't release it for at least a few
days
it's like you don't think Nerf is gonna
come after you yeah Nerf's gonna kill
you for that bro
[Music]
thank you